I think we liked to do that I think that
the nature of the free enterprise system
is one of excess and drought and usually
it gets overdone or underdone and both
of those are not natural good conditions
to fall into but they happen and I think
that because of the way we try to get
hold of the banks after the Great
Depression we've done a much better job
of controlling that particular phenomena
although those sitting here in New York
might not feel that that's been
accomplished necessarily but but I sure
everybody else in America it really has
is that I think that there are a number
of factors that led to it and clearly
they were all related to money being too
cheap is that there was too much money
from globalization going around and
people were not putting the right kinds
of safeguards in place from the mortgage
origination piece of it where people
were able to originate mortgages get
fees and never have any stake and
whether the mortgage ever get paid off
from people who actually took out
mortgages who who knew they couldn't
afford to do it I think we all tend to
feel sorry for everybody that took out
mortgages that couldn't afford them
let's get real here I mean I grew up in
the Midwest if you can't afford you
don't buy it okay so it's not to say
that just the mortgage originators were
evil or the banks were evil everybody
was bad in this whole process the people
who thought they were offloading it
frankly got surprised that it wasn't
truly being offloaded frankly some of
our accounting through mark-to-market
with the SEC rules has caused some of
this issue to occur so there's been a
variety of factors that have led to
Ashley having this happen now the good
news is is that that the Federal
Reserve's come out with some different
standards States who are the
implementing body the regulating excuse
me the legally enforcing body for those
regs I think her to be much more
sensitive to enforcing them particularly
on mortgage originators and I think we
will tend to avoid some of these
problems in the future but the problems
continue to evolve that's a wonderful
thing about a great system of free
enterprise and these people will
continue to get creative these
derivative products they will maybe be
controlled more directly and
future somebody will create a new mouse
trap it will continue they have to try
to chase that but they create huge
amounts of wealth excuse me a huge
amounts of jobs in the meantime and then
there's a lot of pain when it goes too
far and you wish it could all be
self-regulating it just doesn't happen
to be partly because they can't even
tell where the world might go they think
that what is now will always be